in this video we'll talk about
fluorescence correlation spectroscopy or
FCS which is a technique to quantify
molecular Dynamics by looking at the
correlations in fluorescence fluctuation
of course the biomolecule has to be
labeled with any kind of fluorescence
probe
now FCS typically measures time scales
in terms of milliseconds to second level
so FCS is performed using a standard
confocal microscopy if you don't know
how a confocal microscope works you can
quickly look at the video in the I
button or in the description
Now using FCS with proper models and
parameters one can quantify diffusion
coefficients average concentrations
hydrodynamic radius kinetics of chemical
reaction and more complex parameters
like single triplet Dynamics
all these terminologies might be
difficult to understand so let us take
simple example to look at the
application of FCS first and then we
move to understand how we can make sense
of our FCS data
so let's say we want to understand the
diffusion of a lipid particle through
the lipid bilayer and this can be
achieved using FCS measurements
obviously the particular lipid that to
be probed has to be labeled by in any
kind of fluorescence die
now let's say we want to quantify
vesicle trafficking inside the cell in
real time and this can be performed
using FCS let's say we want to look at
the neurotransmitter trafficking through
the axon of a neuron and these kind of
molecular Dynamics can be studied using
the fluorescence correlation
spectroscopy one can calculate the
movement time scale movement kinetics
direction of the movement Etc
now let us try to understand how FCS
measurement work so this is the confocal
objective which is focusing the laser
into a tight diffraction limited spot
and let's say a particular Dynamic
particle marked here in black is moving
across this particular laser volume so
obviously when it moves through the
particular laser volume there is a
fluctuation in intensity that can be
observed by the detector in this case a
detector would be very sensitive camera
now this intensity fluctuation is the
key Essence to understand the FCS data
so let us assume a Time Point T so we
say the fluorescence intensity at the
time Point T is let's say x we have to
understand how this particular intensity
is correlated with another time point
for the same molecule let's say that
time point is t plus tout how could be
any rational value
Now using that or in order to predict
that we use a autocorrelation function
and that autocorrelation function can
actually predict and determine the
overall fluorescence fluctuation over
time and thereby gives us information
about molecular Dynamics
now let us try to understand this
autocorrelation function in a bit more
details so let us assume this particular
molecule is moving across this confocal
volume and we have two time points t and
t plus Tau and we are trying to look at
the fluorescence signal how they are
similar or dissimilar in these two time
points and that that can be predicted by
a fluctuation function let us say f t so
this F T fluctuation function can be
used to determine a autocorrelation
function so the values of f t and f t
plus taus can be calculated from the
confocal image very easily by by drawing
an Roi and quantifying that pixel
intensity of that spot
so just by looking at the pixel
intensity at time T and let's say our
time t plus 5 seconds or 5 milliseconds
one can understand how the fluorescence
fluctuation is happening
now more the fluctuation that means
there is Dynamics if there is no
fluctuation that means the molecule is
stagnant that there thereby there is no
fluctuation
in this particular equation these Open
brackets represent the temporal average
Tau represents in the lag time and GT is
the autocorrelation function so here the
autocorrelation function is the most
important thing that we need to
understand
now this autocorrelation function tells
us about molecular Dynamics how is that
let me show you so let's say we have two
situation in first situation the graph
looks like this and the second situation
the graph looks like this and the second
situation tells you about a restricted
diffusion model in a micro domain of a
membrane
you don't understand anything but a
trained biophysicist can quickly look at
this data and tell you that there is a
slow Decay rate here in the curve and a
fast Decay rate here in the curve so
it's a more complicated dynamics that
has been captured using FCS now let us
try to understand that like a biologist
so in the first example this particular
lipid molecule can diffuse all along the
membrane and that is kind of like a free
diffusion so this diffusion is pretty
fast and the time scale was like pretty
uniform throughout the diffusion time
now in the second case
there are some point of time where the
diffusion is happening slowly and there
are some time where the diffusion is
happening faster
that means there could be restricted
micro domains inside the membrane which
slows down the activity of or movement
of these labeled lipid particles and
exactly that is captured by the
autocorrelation function here in this
FCS measurement now at least you have
some sense that how the autocorrelation
function and the FCS measurement can
tell us lot about the molecular Dynamics
inside a live cell
so there are many pros and cons of
autocorrelation spectroscopy for example
there could be we can measure
quantitatively the diffusion kinetics
very small sample volume is required so
it's great for a single molecular
analysis it can provide direct
measurement of sociometry which is great
but there are a lot of cons for example
one needs a fancy confocal setup for
doing this this kind of fluctuations
which ranges over milliseconds requires
fancy camera with very high frame rate
and these cameras need to determine
single molecular fluctuations that means
the sensitivity camera has to be very
good a back illuminated acmos or a emccd
camera would be appropriate for these
kind of analysis also
there it the data analysis requires
prior knowledge so that means it's not
that simple to do FCS but it's a very
useful biophysical technique which can
tell us lot about the molecular Dynamics
I hope this video was useful if you like
this video give it give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can get more notes and
flashcards in my Facebook page also
follow us in Instagram all the links are
provided in the description you can
support our Channel via super thanks
see you in next video